اذا في اليوم الثاني من قمه مجموعه السبع
اصدر المجتمعون بيانا ختاميا تعهد بمواصله
محاسبه روسيا وكل من يدعمها في حربها على
اوكرانيا واكد البيان الالتزام بدعم
اوكرانيا مهما تطلب احلال السلام الشامل
من وقت وتعهد القاده بالالتزام بتحقيق
عالم خالد من الاسلحه النوويه من خلال
اتباع نهج واقعي وعملي ومسؤول ودعوا الصين
للضغط على روسيا بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا
كما رفضوا قيام الصين بعسكره منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ واكدوا على ضروره بناء
علاقات مستقره مع بيجين بشان الايراني اكد
البيانه على ضروره عدم تطوير ايران سلاحا
نوويا وبان الحل الدبلوماسيه هو افضل
السبل
كما دان البيان القتال الدائره بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لا نتابع هذه
الصور
المباشره من هيروشيما تتابعونها الان حيث
تعقد الان ضمن اعمال قمه الدول السبع جلسه
نقاشيه عن الشراكه من اجل البنيه التحتيه
العالميه والاستثمار
هيروشيما ينضم الينا مراسلنا فادي سلامه
فادي المزيد عن هذا البيان الختامي
وما تضمنه من استعداد للقاده السبع
لمساعده اوكرانيا خلال هذه المرحله في
الحرب
نعم بطبع هذا البيان الختاميه تكون من نحو
40 صفحه ويناقش العديد من القضايا التي
جاء القاده لمناقشتها وفي مقدمتها بالطبع
الغزو او الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا هذه
الحرب شملت جزءا كبيرا من البيان الختامي
وما يرفض الانتباه انه لا يركز فقط على
العقوبات التي ستفرض على روسيا بالحقيقه
كانت هناك عقوبات اعلنت جديده في هذه
القمه اعلنت عنها اليابان وايضا الولايات
المتحده اليابان فرضت عقوبات على 100
شخصيه جديده وايضا الولايات المتحده اضافت
هيئات وكينات وشخصيات لقوائم هذه العقوبات
التي كانت تتكرر خلال القمم السابقه ولكن
في هذه القمه سيتم تشكيل اليه محدده
لمراقبه الدول التي تساعد روسيا على
الالتفاف على هذه العقوبات وسيتم من خلال
هذه الاليه توجيه تحذير لهذه الدول التي
ربما تشتري النفط من روسيا او تشتري
المعادن الثمينه والذهب والالماس الى ذلك
مسؤولون امريكيون الى ان هذه المنتجات
والبضائع ستنفذ في نهايه الامر وحينها
ستتعرض روسيا لاكبر قدر ممكن الضغوط
الاقتصاديه وقد يجبرها ذلك على
التوقف عن هذا العدوان ما وصفه بالعدوان
في اوكرانيا وايضا وجود الرئيس
الاوكراني اليوم الى وحضوره الى هيروشيما
يضيف بالطبع المزيد من الاهميه لهذه القمه
التي كما ذكرت تبحث الان عن خطوات عمليه
للضغط على روسيا الى جانب قضيه اوكرانيا
كان هناك بالطبع جانب كبير من البيان
الختامي شامله ما يتعلق بالصين وما وصفه
قاده مجموعه السبع الاقتصادي الذي تمارسه
الصين ضد الدول الناميه والدول الضعيفه
لتطبيق سياساتها ومصالحها القوميه ايضا
اشار في عشر بنود الى ان في عشره بنود الى
ان الصين شريك اقتصادي مهم واعترفوا
بقوتها الاقتصاديه المتناميه في العالم
ودورها ولكن في نفس الوقت دعوا الصين
للتوقف في عمان وصفوه بالاكراه الاقتصادي
واستخدام الاقتصاد كسلاح للضغط على الدول
وايضا التوسع العسكري الذي تشهده منطقه
اسيا المحيط الهادئ وايضا بحري جنوب الصين
بالتحديد
ومحاولات الصين لتكريسي ما يعرف
بوجودها العسكري هناك سواء من خلال اثبات
او ادعاء والزعم بان لها ملكيه على بعض
الجزر التي تتنازل عليها مع فيتنام
والفلبين وايضا اشاروا في احد البنود
المهمه الى انهم يطالبون ويدعون الصين
لعدم تغيير الوضع الراهن فيما يتعلق بمضيق
تايوان وتهديداتها بغزو بغزو تايوان اضافه
الى ذلك بالطبع هذا البيان شميل نقطه مهمه
تتعلق بنزع السلاح النووي ومنع انتشاره
ودعوا الدول التي تمتلك قوى نوويه وهنا
نذكر بالطبع الولايات المتح
وبريطانيا وفرنسا التي تمتلك رؤوس حربيه
نوويه تمت دعوه هذه الدول للمشاركه في
معاهده عدم الانتشار النووي واطلق رئيس
الوزراء الياباني لاول مره في مثل هذه
القمم قمم السبع بيانا او مبادره جديده
تختلف عن بيان القاده دعاها برؤيه
هيروشيما وهذه الرؤيه تتعلق بنزع السلاح
النووي ومنع انتشاره وبالاضافه لذلك بطبع
ناقش القاده ايضا قضايا اقتصاديه تهم
العالم من بينها العالم بعد كورونا كيف
سيكون الاقتصاد وايضا خطوات مواجهه مثل
الجائحه التي حدثتها وكيف كيفيه التحضير
لها بالاضافه الى الذكاء الاصطناعي
وسيقومون باطلاق منصه تقوم بمراقبه كل ما
يتعلق بتطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي ومنع هذه
التطبيقات من التاثير على الاقتصادات نعم